Krankheiten die man eigentlich dachte besiegt zu haben tauchen plötzlich wieder auf und zwar
gefährlicher denn je und das trotz impfung wären die eigentlich an einem gleichgewicht mit ihrem wird interessiert sind um sich selbst so am besten
auszubreiten werden plötzlich zu
gnadenlosen killers
verschaffen wir uns mit impfung also gerade nur ein paar jahre ruhe vor alten feinden verlieren wir mit ihrer wirksamkeit die
wichtigste waffe der medizin und was tun experten und expertinnen
gegen diesen gefährlichen trend das alles und noch viel mehr jetzt bei klicks um science-fiction herzlich willkommen
Mittlerweile wird schon der dritte impfstoff gegen dem sogenannten marek virus eingesetzt dem killer ganze hühnerhöfe
das virus hat bereits zwei generationen an impfstoffen überwunden und das ist kein einzelfall
sondern ein fataler trend in der medizin in den 60er jahren
wurde der erste impfstoff gegen die marek wären eingeführt zwanzig jahre später waren sie zurück und töteten auch die geimpft
lüner ein weiterer impfstoff kam auf den markt zehn jahre später waren wieder neue viren da und der impfstoff machtlos
mittlerweile ist man beim impfstoff nummer drei angelangt denn die marek wären schaffen es immer wieder die impfstoffe
auszutricksen und forschungsteams
sind ratlos wie das passiert festhalten kann man nur die viren werden immer besser die impfstoffe leider nicht dazu der virologe
jakob trimpert von der uni berlin
dieses virus hat schon ein paar impfstoff generationen überwunden wie im rechten verstehen
warum es nach so mühelos schafft und wie man verhindern könnte dass es dabei immer gefährlicher wird
wenn das marek virus zuschlägt überlebt nur jedes fünfte händchen stelle sind wie leergefegt und die bauern machtlos und es ist besonders tückisch
denn das virus befällt
ausgerechnet die zellen die es beseitigen sollen die immunzellen die viren schleusen ihre eigene dna in die zelle und
vervielfältigen ihr eigenes genmaterial so oft bis das immunsystem
des huhns zusammenbricht das fatale daran die aktuellen erreger sind gefährlicher und aggressiver als diejenigen die
1907 erstmalig beschrieben wurden gilt das etwa auch für andere viren oder bakterien
die erst durch die impfungen besser werden gilt das auch für erreger die mensch
infizieren ins experten und expertinnen sind ratlos denn sie fürchten fatale folgen impfgegner
könnten sich darauf stürzen und die impfraten die derzeit sowieso auf sehr niedrigen niveau sind weiter in den keller stürzen lassen dazu
biologe markus trimpert auf jeden fall ist dass marek virus ein beispiel für eine
ungewöhnlich rasante evolution und die impfung ist höchstwahrscheinlich der motor
seine entwicklung in seinen studien erstellt ja eine evolution skate in der das erbgut der viren von
1940 bis heute aufschlüsselt auffällig dabei die aktuell kursierenden
stämme zeigen eine extrem hohe verwandlung aktivität und zwar bei den
transkriptionsfaktoren
steuereinheiten quasi die die weichen im hühner stoffwechsel so stellen dass das virus sich vermehren kann immer wenn ein neuer impfstoff
eingeführt wird tauchen genau von diesen steuereinheit neue
effektivere varianten auf und gegen diese können dann auch antikörper nichts mehr ausrichten ein riesiges problem
dass man bei der impfstoffentwicklung so bislang noch nicht im blick hatte dazu der us-forscher android
irgendwie gingen immer alle davon aus dass evolution bei impfungen keine rolle spielt ja tut sie aber
und heute sind wir alle live dabei beim größten experiment das die
evolutionsforschung die veranstaltet hat denn bislang stand bei der impfstoffentwicklung immer der sogenannte
mobilisierungs test im mittelpunkt der forschung
bindet das gebildete antikörper nach der impfung fest genug an das oberflächen molekül des
krankheitserregers und markiert den eindringlingen so
dabei spielte in den köpfen der forschungsteams bislang keine rolle ob ein reger in der lage ist dieses markierungs system
auszutricksen manche experten und expertinnen sehen das als hinweis denn impfstoffe von früher
hielten auf erreger wie pocken oder masern die man eben nur einmal im leben haben kann diese viren sind wohl nicht
spezialisiert darauf die immunabwehr von lebewesen zu umgehen und umso aggressiver
zurückzukehren hier gilt also weiterhin wer diese krankheiten einmal hatte und überlebt ist ein leben lang immun
genauso wie diejenigen die geimpft sind also das muss man differenziert betrachten das ist also nicht wasser auf die mühlen von impfgegnern
doch ein fazit das man aus der aktuellen lage ziehen kann ist wohl
dass nicht alle infektionen für impfungen geeignet sind das gilt für diejenigen viren die strategien entwickeln können die antikörper
auszutricksen und dann ein zweites mal
aggressive angreifen darunter zählen auch impfungen die menschen betreffen beispielsweise
haben sich hepatitis b viren und auch die
pneumokokken bakterien seit der zulassung der impfung vor etwa 20 jahren entwickelt die
südostasiatischen mutanten der hepatitis b viren können auch geimpfte anstecken und
verursachen häufiger leberkrebs als die ursprüngliche virusvariante dennoch betonen
forschungsteams
eindringlich das ist kein generelles problem mit impfungen gibt dazu android wir haben ein problem bei den erregern die mit dem immunsystem
interagieren können es gibt immer mehr erreger die auf die impfungen mit
anpassungen reagieren und es bleibt dabei also ganz wichtig impfungen sind die einzige mögliche vorsorge gegen lebensgefährliche
krankheiten nach meinung des experten
müsse den wären die chance auf evolution genommen werden beispielsweise durch hohe impfraten aber auch ein überwachungssystem
das nach in freest enten stemmen sucht wäre denkbar andere forschungsteams sehen eine möglichkeit in der entwicklung von
reserve impfstoffen die man einsetzen könnte wenn es zu neuen ausbrüchen kommt denn es gilt normalerweise
haben wären niemals das ziel tödlich zu sein denn sie sind ja auf ihrem wirt angewiesen um sich auszubreiten
besonders aggressive erreger hatten bei diesen spielern also einen enormen wettbewerbsnachteil
doch genau da vergeht sich jetzt ins gegenteil werden besonders schädlich ist gewinnt
schafft es besonders schnell in die wirtszelle und kann sich am besten aus brighton unter der
voraussetzung dass der wirt organismus geimpft ist wenn die viren aber auf ungeimpfte treffen werden sie zu gnadenlosen killers
so jetzt gibt es ein geschenk für euch vielen dank an technology review in zusammenarbeit mit der redaktion dieser ziemlich guten zeitschrift ist dieses video
entstanden und exklusiv für klicks um zuschauerinnen und zuschauer habe ich jetzt ein geschenk ihr bekommt nämlich eine
ausgabe gratis wenn ihr auf diesen link klickt das lohnt sich absolut ist es eine super
zeitschrift ja und auf jeden fall klicks und natürlich abonnieren das geht hier glocke nicht vergessen und jetzt weiter dafür auch drauf klicken
so fühlt es sich an zu sterben bis dann
bleibt dann